welcome to CBS this morning and we're
going to begin this way with new outrage
by lawmakers over the treatment of
migrants in US custody it's creating
fresh controversy over the crisis at the
southern border Democrats Joaquin Castro
and Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
were among about a dozen members of
Congress who toured the boarder
facilities yesterday now they describe
deplorable conditions inside those
facilities Customs and Border Protection
is also under fire over a secret
Facebook group that includes thousands
of current and former agents some users
reportedly mocked migrant deaths and
posted sexist and racist jokes about
lawmakers including Acacio Cortez Jeff
buguese is outside the agency's
headquarters in Washington good morning
Jeff how is the agency responding well
good morning CBP officials pledged to
investigate those posts and hold people
accountable and this is just more
pressure on an agency that is already
under intense scrutiny and yesterday
lawmakers applied more pressure when
they said that migrants are being held
under horrifying conditions inside Texas
Border Patrol facilities Hispanic Caucus
Chairman Joaquin Castro shot this cell
phone footage of women and CBP custody
saying some had been denied life-saving
medication and showers we saw that the
system is still broken that people's
human rights are still being abused he
was one of several members of the
Hispanic Caucus who toured detention
facilities in Texas
this is CBP on their best behavior
telling people to drink out of the
toilet a CBP official was quoted pushing
back on that statement saying they're
drinking potable water from the sink
attached to the toilet
congresswoman Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
did say this was the type of toilet but
insisted the sink portion was not
functioning she was one of the members
of Congress included in lewd and sexist
Facebook post by CBP employees in a
secret Facebook group uncovered by
ProPublica the Facebook group was dubbed
I'm 10 15 which is Border Patrol code
for aliens in custody one member asked
if this photo of a dead migrant father
and child could have been
fate because the bodies were so clean
there are many within CBP who become
desensitized to the point of being
dangerous to the migrants in their care
CBP officials call the Facebook posts
completely inappropriate these do not
represent the thoughts of the men and
women of the u.s. Border Patrol on
Monday after signing a bill providing
four point six billion dollars in
humanitarian aid at the border President
Trump threatened more deportations were
coming after July fourth a lot of people
are going to be brought back out so
people that come up may be here for a
short while but they're going to be
going they're going back to their
countries they go back home the
president did not get into specifics
about when those apprehensions would
start CBP has also been criticized by
the DHS inspector general about the
conditions inside some of those
detention facilities calling the
conditions overcrowding and conditions
that could lead to violence Tony Jeff
you mentioned the 4.6 billion in
humanitarian aid at the border we know
that won't be going to a border wall but
where might it be going well that of
course is the bill that Congress passed
last week it's a bipartisan bill that
provides for that points 4.6 billion
dollars that will go to humanitarian aid
and security needs most of the money
nearly 2.9 billion dollars goes to
shelter and care for my good children
about 145 million of it will be used for
military missions along the border but
no funding will go toward building the
border wall alright Jeff thank you very
much Jeff PJs for us outside Customs and
Border Protection that Facebook group
secret Facebook group república reports
more than nine thousand members so I
guess it wasn't that secret